the jurogan experience i remember the
first day
that uh i was at twitter um
the at the time
uh the most popular person on twitter
was justin bieber he had more followers
than any other person you know was that
when you guys were trying to rig it
so that he wasn't uh trending number one
always
because they did do that right i don't
remember that no i was oh i don't
remember conveniently
jamie and i were talking about that one
day because they had to do something
because if they didn't do something
justin bieber would be the number one
topic every day
no matter what was happening in the
world i can believe that they wanted to
change that because the pro
the problem was at the time twitter was
held together with like you know
bubble gum and like dental floss or
whatever you know so it's like
every time bieber would tweet like you
know the lights would dim
and like the buildings like kind of
shake a little bit you know here it goes
so they block me from trending this is
2010. i'm actually honored not even matt
he's also 12.
then i get on and see yet again my fans
are unstoppable love you
okay but okay so there's you know people
talk about like invisible labor like the
invisible labor behind that tweet
is just kind of comical because it's
like when he did that you know
people like you know it's like my first
day there you know it's like he
he tweeted something and you know the
building's like kind of shaking and like
alarms are going off people are like
scrambling around you know
and it was just this you know it's like
this realization where you're just like
never
in my life did i think that anything
justin bieber did
would like really affect me in any like
deep way you know and here i am just
like
scrambling around to like facilitate
what are your thoughts on
curating what trends and what doesn't
trend
and whether or not social media should
have any
sort of obligation in terms of
how things whether or not people see
things like shadow banning and things
along those lines like
i i'm very torn on this stuff because i
i
i think that things should just be and
if you have a situation where justin
bieber is the most popular thing on the
internet
that's just what it is it is what it is
but i also get it i get how you would
say well this is going to [ __ ] up our
whole
program like what we're trying to do
with this thing
what do you mean [ __ ] up our whole
program well what you're trying to do
with twitter i mean i would assume what
you're trying to do is
give people a place where they could
share
important information and you know have
people
you know i mean twitter has been used
successfully to overturn
governments i mean there's there's
twitter has been used to
break news on very important events and
alert people to danger and there's
there's so many positive things about
twitter and if
if it's overwhelmed by justin bieber and
justin bieber fan
accounts and justin bieber if it's
overwhelmed then the top 10 things
that are trending are all nonsense
i could see how someone would think
we're going to do a good thing by
suppressing that
yeah i see what you're saying why do you
think they did suppress that
what do you think you worked there why
do you think they kept him from trending
um well i mean
i don't know about that specific
situation i mean i think
i think you know looking at the larger
picture right like
um in a way
you know it's like if you think about
like 20 years ago whenever anybody
talked about like
society you know um everyone would
always
say like the problem is the media it's
like the media man
you know if only we could change the
media and a lot of people
in who were interested in like a better
and brighter future
were really focused on self-publishing
their whole conferences about a great
underground publishing conference now
the allied media conference
people were writing zines uh people were
you know getting their own printing
presses
uh people you know we were convinced
that if we
um made publishing
more equitable if everybody had the
equal ability to like produce and
consume content that the world would
change
and in some ways
like what we have today is like
the fantasy of you know those dreams
from 20 years ago
but in a couple ways you know like
uh one you know it was it was it was the
dream that if you know
a cop kill some random person in the
suburbs of st louis
that like everyone would know about it
you know
just um do you know everyone knows um
and also
that anybody could share their weird
ideas about the world you know
and i think in some ways um
we were wrong you know that we thought
uh
like you know the what we got today is
like yeah like if a cop killed somebody
in
in the suburbs of saint louis like
everybody knows about it i think we
overestimated how much that would matter
uh and i think we also believed that the
things that everyone would be sharing
were like our weird ideas about the
world and instead we got like you know
flat earth and
uh like you know uh anti-vaxx and like
you know
stuff right uh and so it's like in a
sense like i'm glad that those things
exist because they're like
they're sort of what we wanted you know
uh but i think
what we did what we underestimated is
like how uh
important the medium is like the medium
is the message kind of thing and that
like
what we were doing at the time of like
you know writing zines and sharing
information we i don't think we
understood how much
that was predicated on like actually
building community and like
relationships with each other and that
like just
um like what we didn't want was just
like more channels on the television
and that's sort of what we got you know
and so i think you know it's like
everyone is like on youtube trying to
monetize their content whatever you know
and that
it's the same thing like bad business
models produce like bad technology and
bad outcomes and
so i think there's concern about that
but i think
um i think like
you know now that there's there's like
you know these two simultaneous truths
that everyone seems to believe that are
in contradiction with each other you
know like one
is that like um everything is relative
uh everyone is entitled to their own
opinion all opinions are equally valid
and two like um
our democracy is impossible without a
shared understanding of what is true and
what is false
the information that we share needs to
be verified by our most trusted
institutions
like people seem to simultaneously
believe both of these things and yeah
um they're in direct contradiction with
each other um
and so in some ways i think most of the
questions about you know social media
and our time are about like trying to
resolve those contradictions
and but i think you know um
i think it's way more complicated than
the way
uh that the social media companies are
trying to portray it
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience